- Welcome back, everybody.
With musicians like
Beyonce, Drake, and Selena
all collaborating with Afrobeats artists,
the Afrobeats genre is beginning
to truly dominate the US pop music scene.
Our next guest is known
as the King of Afrobeats.
He's had the longest
charting Nigerian song
in Billboard history, no big deal,
and the first Nigerian music video
to reach a hundred
million views on YouTube.
His new album is called
Timeless. It's out now.
Everybody please give a
warm welcome for David O.
(audience clapping)
You look so cool.
- Thank you.
You out here looking so cool in pink, yes!
- I must, I must say this,
I grew up watching you and-
- Oh!
- Yeah, my sister,
my older sister was the
biggest Kelly Clarkson fan.
- Oh my God. Well, she has
better taste than you then.
- So she, yeah-
- I'm just kidding.
- So I'm honored to be here,
you know, it's a dream come true.
- You know, all the way from
Africa to, you know, be here
with all you guys, it's cool.
- Oh, no, thank you. Thank you as well.
Thank you for coming. Okay.
So like, I love this story.
Your dad,
- Yeah.
- Was very upset with you
that you left school, right?
Because you wanted to,
you wanted to produce,
you wanted to write-
- Yeah. My family, I come
from a big, big family
that's really big on education.
Like I'm first generation
entertainer in my,
in my whole line of blood, bloodline.
- So...
- You know what I'm saying? So he was,
- They were not excited.
- He was, he was,
He was really adamant
about me finishing school.
One, because I hadn't made it yet.
- Yeah.
- Two because, you know what I'm saying?
He, he didn't mind me doing music,
but he was really bent on me,
you know, finishing school.
He owns a university.
- Yeah.
- So you can-
- He owns a university and
you didn't stay in school?
- So you, so, so you can imagine.
And my mom's,
- Oh my God.
- My mom was a college
professor, so imagine.
- Oh my gosh.
- I think they, I think
they're also scared
'cause they want, whatever
you want your kids to do,
you want 'em to be successful in it.
- Yeah.
- In our business, it's not
that easy to be successful.
So, you know, we kind of made
a deal where I go to school
like two weeks out of the month
and the other two weeks
I can be in the studio
and then do what I want.
- How did that deal work
out with the classroom?
Because you just-
- So, and then the deal also, you know,
my dad is a very successful man, you know,
- Yeah.
- Very wealthy.
So I was like, all right, you going,
you gonna gimme some bread for my music?
- I love you so much.
You're like, you set
me up, I will do this.
- Yeah, so that, that was really the deal.
But the thing is that my
music was always good,
you know what I'm saying?
And he knew that.
So the more I was going
away for two weeks,
doing the music, dropping videos,
my music was getting-
- Bigger.
- Yeah.
- So it got to a point where
I was a distraction to the class.
So I'm like, yes!
- I love it.
Yes. I've made it.
- Yeah. Like, I was a
distraction to the class.
So I'm like, I don't even
gotta leave by myself.
They, they telling me to get
out, you know what I'm saying?
- I love it.
- You know, so after a while
then I, I kind of had to do
like a part-time class type stuff.
- Yeah.
- And then I was getting too
big and then he got mad, mad.
I'm talking about he see a
billboard of me doing a show,
the show gets canceled
before I even get there.
- Oh my God.
- He has that type of power.
- Hardcore.
- Yeah, that type of power.
- What a powerful man.
- You know what I'm saying?
So it got to a point where
everybody was being scared to book me,
you know what I'm saying?
So I'm like, you know what,
- This is a movie.
- Yeah. No, this is crazy.
- Your life is a movie.
- This is crazy.
So at that time I had
a song that was like,
and at this time I had
a song probably like,
was like top 20 on the charts in Africa.
But then the next song
I made went number one,
like the president of-
- Congrats.
The president's like rocking out.
- The president, the
president of the country,
my song was his ringtone.
So like after that I was, after that like-
- You're like, I'm not showing
up for class. So, sorry bro.
- So eventually though,
you know, I went back
and I, I did finish 'cause I only
had like a year and a half left.
So eventually, yeah, I did finish though.
- I love that your dad though,
he's seen you like being all
successful on billboards,
like no, I'm gonna shut that down.
You made a deal.
- Yeah, you made a deal.
- You made a deal.
- And now he's the biggest fan.
- Oh, I love that.
- Biggest fan.
- It was important, that's amazing.
It's supportive in a chaotic way.
It's like, so wait, you
name the album Timeless.
- Timeless, yes.
- And then I heard, did you go in,
I've actually done this before.
- Yeah.
- Because your life kind of changes
and it alters some of the songs.
So I heard you went in and rerecorded
some of the music for it.
- Yeah, yeah, definitely.
You know how it is,
like we know how it is
when you sit on something for so long,
- Yeah.
- You get tired and then you just,
I kind of got in a different space.
- Yeah.
- You know, when like the
album was getting finished.
So I told the label, I was like, yo,
can I get like three, four more months?
You know? I went back
home to my key producers,
the people that I was
working with in the hood,
before I left to all
the glitz and glamour.
Like, I went back to the hood.
And I brought everybody
together and we all sat down
and under three months
we completed the album.
And it's my biggest, biggest
charting album till date.
- Man, congratulations.
That's so awesome.
I love the coming back
to like the, your crew.
- Yeah.
- When you first were inspired,
and you first were like,
there's nothing like that high,
you know, whenever you're
first getting started.
I love that.
- Of course.
And you know, with our music,
of course there's a lot
of like Afro Fusion,
of course we get inspired
by people like you,
people over here, rappers...
- Inspired by everything.
- Yeah, but with this record,
I really wanted to take it back home.
- And it's being respected worldwide.
You know what I'm saying?
That's just amazing.
- Yeah. Oh my gosh, everybody.
Let's do a quick commercial break.
David O's new album is called
Timeless. It's out now.
It's incredible. You gotta check it out.
You can also join him at this
Are We African Yet? festival
in Atlanta on November 18th.
We'll be right back everybody.